dwayne johnson and vin diesel are both
mighty action a-listers on their own but
these days the merest mention of the two
together invokes images of their
long-running rumored feud this has been
going on since 2016 when johnson gave
his famous candy-ass comments about a
fast and furious franchise co-star who
was generally thought to be diesel in a
2021 interview with men's health diesel
didn't exactly back down but stated that
whatever slides johnson might have
perceived on his part were merely quote
a lot of tough love in order to get the
best out of johnson for his role as luke
hobbs recently the book of johnson and
diesel received a brand new chapter
thanks to an instagram post by the
latter seemingly written in order to
bring johnson back for one last run as
hobbs it started my little brother
dwayne the time has come the world
awaits the finale of fast 10. as you
know my children refer to you as uncle
dwayne in my house there is not a
holiday that goes by that they and you
don't send well wishes but the time has
come legacy awaits after some words
about needing to wrap up the franchise
to honor pablo presumably paul walker
diesel directly called for johnson's
return the post read i say this out of
love but you must show up do not leave
the franchise idol you have a very
important role to play hobs can't be
played by no other i hope that you rise
to the occasion and fulfill your destiny
during the promotion circuit of the
dwayne johnson starring netflix action
comedy red notice johnson's business
partner hyrum garcia shared his views
about vin diesel's olive branch to
johnson according to screenrant
presumably referring to either the
entertainment world in general or diesel
and the fast and furious franchise in
particular garcia said look you can
never predict or control what's going to
come out of that world so i'm very used
to it by now i think we're both very
used to it garcia also said that while
he hasn't exactly been able to sit down
with his super famous business partner
to have a lengthy talk about the recent
developments he's personally not all
that surprised about the latest news he
revealed i haven't been able to really
connect with dj on it because he's been
buried in promoting red notice but yeah
i'm used to it it's what comes with that
world you get crazy curveballs thrown
and you just roll with it garcia's
comments are carefully phrased but they
certainly sound like this isn't exactly
the first time that he's been dealing
with assorted statements directed at
johnson there seems to be some sort of
unwritten law that any new development
and the ever intriguing feud between vin
diesel and dwayne johnson must include
at least one subtle not quite this that
may or may not be aimed toward the other
party
and hiram garcia's comments were no
exception to the rule in fact if
anything he was fairly direct in his
shade throwing it's the fast family look
dj is the biggest movie star in the
world no one's below trying all attempts
and approaches to try and get him on
board so i appreciate it he got to take
your shirt you never know i'm sure
there's a couple dms that slid in there
too i'm sure he slid into the dms as
well conjuring an image of diesel
sliding into its former co-stars dms in
order to bring johnson back for one more
movie makes it pretty clear where garcia
stands when it comes to this subject
even though it does make sense that the
fast and furious star would indeed
greatly benefit if johnson agreed to
return to the fast family for a final
victory lap as for johnson himself his
apparently official stance on the
subject was issued in his july 2021
interview with the hollywood reporter
which heavily indicated that he's done
with the franchise he said i wish them
well on f9 and they wish them the best
of luck on fast 10 and fast 11 and the
rest of the fast and furious movies they
do that will be without me it remains to
be seen whether there will be new
developments on the johnson and diesel
front or if garcia's comments remain the
final word on the subject check out one
of our newest videos right here plus
even more looper videos about your
favorite movies are coming soon
subscribe to our youtube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one
[Music]